Ich bin der für Sie zuständige Arzt hier. Darf ich Sie zuerst einmal um Ihren Namen bitten?
Ja, ich heiße Oskar Schmidt.
Herr Oskar, können Sie Ihren Vornamen langsam bestabieren?
Ja, mein Familienname ist Schmidt. Also Oskar ist der Vorname O-S-K-A-R.
Oskar, ein ziemlich altes Wurzelname.
Schmidt ist ja sehr geläufig. S-C-H-M-I-D-T am Ende.
D-T, ja. Danke, Herr Schmidt. Ich brauche erstmal ein paar persönliche Daten und dann sprechen wir etwas genauer über Ihre Beschwerden.
Bitte fragen Sie noch, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 17.9.75.
17.9.75. 1975. Ich bin also noch 50 Jahre alt.
40 Jahre, ja. Verstehe. Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, ich bin 1,79 und wiege 95 Kilo.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
95 Kilo.
95 Kilo, ja. Verstehe. Herr Schmidt, was kann ich für Sie sagen? Was über Schwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Ich habe schon so lange so komisches Aufstoßen und so Schmerzen hier im unteren Halsbereich.
Das wird immer mehr. Das brennt. Ich habe Probleme beim Schlucken.
Manchmal ist es so, dass ich ziemlich starke Soht brennen habe und dann weiß ich gar nicht, was ich dagegen machen soll.
Mein Hausarzt hat mir zwar ein Medikament gegeben, das gegen die Säure im Magen helfen soll, aber das hat bisher wirklich nicht so viel gebracht.
Besonders schlimm ist es, wenn ich mich relativ schnell nach dem Essen hinlege zum Schlafen.
Wenn ich spät noch etwas esse und im Liegen passiert mir das dann schon mal, was hochkommt.
Scharfes Essen kann ich gar nicht mehr vertragen.
Da merke ich dann sofort, dass das hinterher richtig doll brennt.
Komischerweise kann ich auch nicht so gut Kaffee vertragen und Schokolade.
Ich esse eigentlich sehr gerne Schokolade, aber danach muss ich immer büßen.
Da ist es dann immer besonders schlimm mit den Schmerzen.
Nach Kaffee und Schokolade? Ja, sowohl als auch.
Sie haben gesagt ein Medikament, aber wie heißt es?
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie das heißt. Irgendetwas mit T meint ich.
Aber das soll halt irgendwie die Säure ein bisschen stoppen.
Herr Schmidt, seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Das hat schon lange angefangen, aber das war nie so schlimm wie jetzt.
Ich war ja auch schon beim Hausarzt, der hat mir diese Tabletten verschrieben.
Jetzt muss ich aber auch noch etwas dazu sagen.
Ich habe einen Bruder, bei dem hat man festgestellt, dass der Speiseröhr einen Krebs hat.
Jetzt habe ich wahnsinnige Angst, dass ich so etwas vielleicht auch habe.
Das können Sie vielleicht verstehen, weil der auch sagt, er hat Schluckbeschwerden und es brennt.
Jetzt habe ich natürlich ganz besondere Angst, ich komme doch mal gleich zu Ihnen.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgezettelt?
Das hat langsam angefangen, ja.
Das war dann auch nicht ständig, sondern insbesondere, wenn ich dann extreme Sachen gegessen habe.
Oder wenn ich mal Schnaps getrunken habe.
Danach war es dann immer besonders schlecht.
Das war im Legen.
Herr Schmidt, waren die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nein, das ist eigentlich nur hier im Halsbereich und ein bisschen weiter runter.
Sind die Schmerzen, Sie haben gesagt, nicht immer da?
Am Anfang war ich da, jetzt sind sie fast ständig da, würde ich sagen.
Deswegen bin ich dann jetzt auch gekommen, weil es immer mehr wurde.
Sind die Schmerzen vom Ausgangsort an einen anderen Ort gewandert?
Nein, das war immer da im Halsbereich.
Können Sie bitte genau das zeigen?
Ja, also hier so.
So bis zum Brustansatz runter, so ungefähr.
Ich verstehe das, im Verlauf der Zeit, sind die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden.
Sie sind schlimmer geworden, ja.
Und auch häufiger und schlimmer.
Hatten Sie so etwas früher schon einmal? Sie haben gesagt lange, aber?
Nein, also ich habe das früher nicht gehabt, nein.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Krampfartig oder schneidend oder brennend?
Ja, brennend beschreibt das, glaube ich, am besten, ja.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1-10?
Wobei 1 sehr leichte Schmerzen und 10 sehr starke Schmerzen ist.
Ja, das ist schon ein bisschen unterschiedlich, aber so um die Mitte rum, würde ich sagen.
Mal ein bisschen weniger als 5 und mal ein bisschen mehr als 5.
Aber es ist eigentlich jetzt immer so, dass es unangenehm ist und dass es mich auch beim Essen stört.
Und dass es so eine Beeinträchtigung ist, so eine ständige Beeinträchtigung.
Gibt es bestimmt Auslöser für die Schmerzen, für diese Beschwerden?
Ja, habe ich ja gesagt.
Ja, Essen, ja, ja. Vielleicht noch andere. Vielleicht Essen, ja.
Ja, und Schnaps trinken, ja. Das lasse ich natürlich jetzt auch weg schon seit Läckerem.
Kaffee, Schokolade, ja.
Ja, also manchmal trinkt man ja doch mal einen Kaffee oder...
Ja, vielleicht ist der Kaffee dann auch, was weiß ich, wenn man den mit irgendwas dazu morgens trinkt, dann geht es vielleicht.
Ja, vielleicht, aber wenn man nur Kaffee trinkt, ist vielleicht schlechter. Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber das habe ich gemerkt, dass starker Kaffee ist nicht gut.
Haben Sie sonst noch irgendwelche anderen Beschwerden bemerkt?
Na ja, ich schlafe halt nicht mehr gut, weil ich so dieses Gefühl habe, dass ich so aufstoßen muss.
Und morgens, also nachts, muss ich auch oft so ein bisschen husten.
Da habe ich so einen Hustenreis, da muss ich mich mit einem Mal aufsetzen und husten.
Und meistens muss ich dann auch aufstehen und einen Schluck Wasser trinken.
Und morgens bin ich auch so ein bisschen kratzig im Hals, dann bin ich heißer, ne?
Ja, heißer, ja. Gibt es bestimmt eine Körperhaltung, die dich schmerzen, fester oder...
Ja, also für den Augenblick ist es halt immer so ein gutes Gefühl, wenn man einen Schluck kaltes Wasser trinkt, ne?
Ja, nur Wasser trinken, ja.
Herr Schmit, jetzt kommen wir zu Ihrem allgemeinen Zustand.
Herr Schmit, wie ist Ihr Apathie?
Na ja, also zur Zeit ist es ja nicht so gut. Ich habe eigentlich immer...
Na ja, also die 95 Kilo, ne, die kommen ja nicht von ungefähr.
Aber ich habe auch schon deutlich mehr gehabt, ja.
Also ich habe in den letzten drei Monaten, würde ich sagen, habe ich bestimmt drei Kilo abgenommen.
Oh, drei Kilo.
Ja, einfach weil es mir nicht gut schmeckt und weil das Essen unangenehm ist, ne?
Drei Kilo, aber in welchem Zeitraum?
Drei Monate.
Ah, drei Monate, ja. Okay. Aber wie viel?
Ja, morgens, also nachts vor allen Dingen, und morgens bin ich heiser, ne?
Ja.
Aber sonst habe ich eigentlich keine Noten.
Ja. Ist der Husten trocken oder mit Ausruf?
Ne, da kommt nichts. Also das ist nur gereizt, ja, nur trocken.
Ja, gereizt, ja. Leiden Sie unter Luftnot?
Luftnot? Nein, nein.
Ja. Ja. Fühlen Sie sich fieberig, haben Sie Fieber, Schüttelfrost, Nachtschweiß, Kalzschweiß, Schweißausbrüche?
Schweißausbrüche habe ich nicht, ne. Also das ist eigentlich, also auch nachts muss ich nicht schwitzen.
Also wie gesagt, nachts mache ich manchmal auch, weil ich husten muss und weil es dann eben so im Hals kratzt, ne?
Ja. Aber Sie haben kein Fieber.
Also ich fühle mich nicht fieberig.
Ja, ja, ja.
Steht etwas.
Ja. Haben Sie verstärkten Durst bemerkt?
Was habe ich?
Verstärkten Durst, mehr Durst.
Mehr? Nein, eigentlich, das ist eigentlich nur das Gefühl, dass ich manchmal so etwas hinterher trinken will, um das zu verdünnen.
Wegen dieser Beschwerden, ja.
Aber sonst trinke ich glaube ich nicht mehr als sonst, ne?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuken oder was alles?
Gott sei Dank noch nicht.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, ob Sie schon einmal das Bewusstsein verloren haben?
Ne, also das habe ich glaube ich noch nie erlebt, nein.
Haben Sie Erbrochen, Übelkeit?
Übelkeit, manchmal so ein bisschen, aber erbrechen Gott sei Dank nicht, nein.
Ja, ja. Wird Ihnen schwindelig oder schwarz vor den Augen?
Nein, nein, nein. Ich habe diese Halsschmerzen, wissen Sie?
Ja, ja. Sie haben gesagt, wegen dieser Beschwerden schlafen Sie nicht gut.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, ja.
Herr Schmidt, jetzt kommen wir zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte. Gibt es chronische Krankheiten, an denen Sie leiden?
Nein, ich war immer ganz gesund. Das Einzige, was der Hausarzt jetzt mal festgestellt hat, dass ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe, ja.
Aber das ist nicht mal so, dass der mir jetzt Medikamente verschieben hat, ne?
Sondern das ist nur so, dass er gesagt hat, ja, bewegen Sie sich viel und versuchen Sie Gewicht abzunehmen.
Na ja, gut so.
Aber gibt es noch andere Krankheiten?
Nee, sonst habe ich nichts, zum Glück.
Und kein Medikament?
Nein, also wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe, dann nehme ich mal Aspirin, ja.
Wie viel Milligramm Aspirin?
Bitte?
Wie viel Milligramm?
Boah, was steht denn da drauf? Ich glaube, da steht 500 drauf.
Ja, ja, 500.
Noch ein oder andere Medikament regeln Sie bei Bedarf? Niemals?
Nee, wie gesagt, dieses vom Hausarzt, aber das habe ich dann auch gar nicht mehr genommen, weil es eh nicht geholfen hat.
Vielleicht Pantoprosol.
Das könnte sein, dass das so heißt.
Aber es hat nicht geholfen.
Pantoprosol.
Verstehen Sie jetzt?
Sind Ihnen Allergien oder Unverschwerigkeiten bekannt?
Lassen Sie mich überlegen. Ich habe eigentlich nie irgendwie eine Hautreaktion oder...
Ja.
Ich kann alles vertreten. Wie gesagt, ich war bisher immer ganz gesund.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich erinnere mich.
Herr Schmidt, jetzt kommen wir Ihrer Familie anzustanden.
Ihre Familie.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Oh nein, das wäre ja ein Wunder. Die sind ja schon sehr alt.
Ich bin ja schon 50. Also, nee, die leben beide nicht mehr.
Woran sind Sie gestorben?
Ja, also ich weiß nur, dass mein Vater hohen Blutdruck hatte und meine Mutter, die hatte einen Schlaganfall.
Schlaganfall, ja. Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben einen Bruder, oder?
Ja, genau.
Noch andere Geschwister?
Ja, eine Schwester habe ich noch.
Noch eine Schwester. Sie ist sehr gesund. Ihr Bruder hat eine Speiseröhre.
Da hat man festgestellt vor ein paar Jahren, dass sie MS hat.
MS.
Das ist natürlich, ja, im Augenblick geht es ihr noch leidlich, aber das ist natürlich, das schwebt so über ihr.
Herr Schmidt, rauchen Sie?
Ja, also nicht mehr so viel wie früher, aber so 10 Zigaretten bis ein Päckchen rauche ich schon am Tag noch.
Ja, seit wann?
Seit 30 Jahren.
30 Jahre. Wie viele Zigaretten früher?
Früher habe ich ein Päckchen und mehr geraucht und jetzt rauche ich eher ein bisschen weniger als ein Päckchen.
Ja, ja. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke eigentlich ziemlich regelmäßig ein Bier und wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt, auch mal Wein oder so, oder zum guten Essen mal Wein.
Ja, und je nachdem, wenn man auch mal mit Freunden zusammen ist, trinke ich auch wohl mal ein Schnäpschen oder so.
Aber wie gesagt, das habe ich in letzter Zeit eben nicht gut bekommen.
Regelmäßig Bier? Wie viel?
Ja, also eine Flasche wenigstens.
Ja, bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich, aber das ist eine gute Frage. Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nicht mehr. In meinen wilden Jahren habe ich mal ein bisschen haschig geraucht, ja, aber das ist schon lange her.
Ja, wie viel mal?
Na ja, vielleicht so über zwei Jahre oder so, dass ich mal hin und wieder mal joint geraucht habe.
Ja, ja.
So in der Ausbildungszeit und so.
Ja, ja. Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Schreiner.
Schreiner?
Ich bin aber zum Glück nicht selbstständig, sondern habe keine eigene Firma, sondern bin angestellt in der Schreinerei.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Ja, haben Sie Kinder?
Einen Sohn haben wir, ja.
Einen Sohn?
Ja.
Ist er gesund?
Der ist gesund, ja, ja.
Gott sei Dank, ja. Ich denke, Sie wohnen mit Ihrer Familie zusammen.
Bitte was?
Mit Ihrer Familie. Ich denke, Sie wohnen mit Ihrer Familie zusammen.
Wir leben alle zusammen, ja, ja, natürlich, ja.
Ja, ja.
Hör ich mit, wann waren Sie das nächste Mal im Ausland, Urlaub oder Urlaub?
Das ist schon zwei Jahre her. Da waren wir mal in Spanien, aber das ist schon ewig her.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie können gut bewegen gegen Bluthochdruck.
Was?
Aber wenn Sie Sport...
Eben nicht. Also ich müsste ein bisschen mehr machen. Ich fahre ein bisschen Fahrrad, ja.
Fahrrad, ja.
Echt?
Herr Schmidt, Sie haben gesagt, drei Kilogramm nur, aber innerhalb von drei Monaten...
...dürfe ich auf und abnehmen, ja.
Aber keine Kaltschweiß nach Schweiß, verstehe ich, ja.
Ja, ist richtig.
Ja.
Haben Sie schon einmal einen Tierstuhl bemerkt?
Ein was habe ich bemerkt?
Ja, schwarzen Stuhl, Tierstuhl.
Schwarzen Stuhl?
Nein, das sieht immer braun aus, ja.
Tierstuhl, ja.
Und Blut, der Husten mit Blutauswurf.
Ja, der Husten ist immer trocken. Ich muss kein Blut husten, nein.
Da ist der Husten, Sie haben gesagt, ja.
Okay.
Herr Schmidt, wir sind jetzt fertig. Und danke für Ihre Geduld und Ihre Mitarbeit.
Haben Sie noch Informationen, die wichtig sein könnten?
Ich denke, Sie haben ja so viel gefragt und ich habe Ihnen so viele Einzelheiten erzählt.
Ich denke, dass Sie über alles jetzt Bescheid wissen, ja.
Okay.
Okay, möchte jemand noch etwas fragen?
Hallo.
Sie haben schon gesagt, ja, oder ich habe Sie richtig verstanden, Sie haben eine Schluckstörung.
Gibt es eine Zunahme der Schluckstörung?
Ja, ein bisschen mehr ist das geworden, ja.
Ist das gegen Flüssigkeiten auch oder nur feste Dinge?
Eigentlich überwiegend bei fester Nahrung, ja.
Fester Nahrung.
Haben Sie Belehrung auch?
Belehrungen?
Ja.
Nicht besonders, nein.
Volle Gefühle?
Volle Gefühle.
Manchmal so ein bisschen, ja.
Ja, also insbesondere, also wenn ich spät vor dem Schlafen gehe noch was esse, dann habe ich so das Gefühl, ja, dass es eigentlich so ein bisschen zu viel war und dass es drückt, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Gewöhnlichkeit, heißes Essen zu essen oder Kaffee zu trinken?
Ja, ich mag nicht gerne kalte Sachen trinken, das stimmt, ja.
Also warme Getränke trinke ich gerne heiß, ja. Und warmes Essen esse ich auch gerne heiß, ja.
Warme und heiß, ja?
Mhm.
Okay.
Herr Dr. Troll, weil Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn Sie so weit sind, ne?
Ja.
Gut. Geht schon? Oder brauchen Sie noch einen Moment?
Ja, einen Moment, ja.
Guten Tag, Frau Oberhörstin. Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und wenn Sie Zeit haben, möchte ich Ihnen den Falkurs vorstellen, darf ich?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja. Der Patient heißt Oskar Schmid.
Herr Schmid ist 50 Jahre alt. Er ist 179 groß, 1 Meter, 79 groß und wiegt 95 Kilogramm.
Herr Schmid stellt sich heute bei uns wegen seit lange Jahren aufgetretener, Entschuldigung, lange Jahren bestechender, langsam aufgetretener als mediastinal Schmerzen.
Das heißt mediastinal Schmerzen vor. Der Patient beschreibt die Schmerzen als brennend und ihre Schmerzintensität liegt aktuell bei 5 von 10 auf einer Skala.
Die Schmerzen, die Beschwerden seien im Laufe der Zeit progredient. Die Schmerzen strahlen unten aus.
Wo strahlen die?
Strahlen unten hinter aus.
Nach hinten?
Ja.
Ok.
Verstehe ich. Falsch.
Ich habe es akustisch nicht verstanden.
Ja, ja.
Die Beschwerden, die Schmerzen würden sich beim Spätessen, vor dem Schlafessen oder beim Liegen erstarken und nach dem Wasser trinken nachlassen.
Ok.
Gegen die Schmerzen habe der Patient, denke ich, Pantoprosol eingenommen, aber es hat keine Verbesserung gebracht.
Er hat keine endlichen Beschwerden früher gehabt.
Die Beschwerden würden mit voller Gefühl, Dol und Halskrass und Heißen die Stimme stürmen.
Was war das zweite?
Heiß, Heiß, Heiß, Stimme stürmen.
Also mit voller Gefühl, das zweite?
Dol.
Was ist Dol?
Dolgefühl, ja.
Voller Gefühl.
Und ja, verstehe ich. Entschuldigung, Vollgefühl.
Ach, voller Gefühl. Ok.
Ja, ja. Halskrass.
Ja, ich möchte wieder sagen, die Beschwerden würden mit voller Gefühl, Halskrass und Heiß einhergehen.
Die Frage nach Tiersturmblechungen wurde vermeint.
Und noch andere begleitende Symptome sind in Appetens Gewichtabnahme, 3 kg innerhalb 3 Monate und nachtliche Tussis, Reisetussis.
Und so brennen Neusea und Insomnie.
Die andere vegetative Anamnese war unaufällig.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte er eine arterielle Hypertonik und in der operativen Anamnese, er hat keine Operation durchgeführt.
Er hat bisher noch keine Operation überstanden.
Ja. Und er habe keine Allergie oder Unfertigkeiten.
Er nehme regelmäßig kein Medikament, aber bei Bedarf gegen Kopfschmerz, Aspirin.
Nehme er Aspirin und ja, nur Aspirin.
In Besuch auf die Familienanamnese gab er an, dass ihr Vater an arterieller Hypertonik verstorben ist und die Mutter an Insult verstorben ist.
Der Patient raucht seit 30 Jahren. Früher rauhe er ca. 20 Zigaretten, aber jetzt ca. 10 Zigaretten rauhe er.
Der Patient trinke regelmäßig ein Flasche Bier, manchmal trinke er Wein.
Der Drogenkonsum wurde verneint. Der Patient ist von Beruf Schreiner und ist verheiratet, aber ein gesunder Sohn und wohnt mit seiner Familie zusammen.
Mit seiner Familie.
Er treibt Sport, aber als Fahrrad fährt er.
Als Sport betreibt er Fahrradfahren.
Ja, treibt Fahrrad.
Aufgrund der anamnestischen Angaben gehe ich von einem Verdacht auf eine gastroesefagiale Reflüge.
Und da der Patient typische Symptome ausweist.
Aber es kommt Differentialdiagnostik in Betracht?
Ja, ja, ja. Differentialdiagnostik kommen.
Es ist ein Phagialcarcinom und der Gastrik ist in Betracht.
Genau, was machen Sie diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Ja, ja.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch?
Ja, zunächst würde ich die Vitalparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ja, bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich besonders auf epigastrischen Druckschmerz und die Anamnestichen.
Ah ja, genau.
Und er hat gesagt Schluckstörungen und ja, diese Agen, es gelten als Alarmsymptome wie Dysphage.
Ja, ich achte darauf diese Sachen.
Und wie geht er wieder? Und bestimmen die Gewichtverlust?
Wie viel er jetzt aktuell wiegt?
Ja, aktuell, ja.
Gut, ja, was machen Sie noch?
Jetzt gehe ich Blutuntersuchung.
Jetzt würde ich den Patienten Blut abnehmen und folgende Parameter bestimmen lassen.
Kleines Blutbild würde ich bestimmen lassen.
Und für den Blutverlust bestimmen lassen. Das heißt Anämie.
Anämietech?
Ja, Entzündungsparameter, CRP.
Und vielleicht herzliche Krankheiten, um herzliche Krankheiten auszuschließen.
Um was für Krankheiten auszuschließen?
Um Herzkrankheiten auszuschließen.
Ja, ja, ja. Herzentzüme.
Ja, ja.
Gut, ja. Und was bietet sich noch als diagnostische Maßnahme an?
Die wichtigste ist, ein zentrales diagnostisches Verfahren ist hier.
Die wichtigste ist, ja.
Des Weiteren plane ich eine ösefagro-gastrodiodroskopie zu diesen Krankheiten,
die zum Beispiel Oesopagel-Carsenam oder Gastro-Gastrodiodroskopie beurteilen.
Bei dieser Untersuchung kann ich eine Gewebe-Untersuchung, eine Biopsie, entnehmen.
Eine Biopsie entnehmen, ja. Genau.
Gut, und wenn sich jetzt Ihre Diagnose bestätigt, was wäre dann Ihr Therapievorschlag?
Ja, ja. Sollte ich die Verdacht Diagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten in der normalen Weise
ambulant behandeln. Ich würde ambulant behandeln, aber ja.
Und was würden Sie ihm vorschlagen?
Ja, ich würde den Patienten folgende empfehlen.
Zum Beispiel Lebensstilveränderung, zum Beispiel Nikotinkarenz, Alkoholkarenz, Gewicht.
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, aber ich denke, er ist ein bisschen...
Er ist bestimmt übergewichtig mit 95 Kilo, ja?
Ja, wegen dieser Situation.
Gewichtsverlust ist die wichtigste als Empfehlung.
Ja, vielleicht fett reichen
Ja, ja, ja.
Entschuldigung, spät essen.
Vor dem Schlaf brauchen wir mehr Zeit.
Spät essen, jetzt habe ich es verstanden. Also nicht spät essen.
Ja, ja.
Okay, ja. Dass er nicht direkt vor dem Schlaf noch was isst. Ja, okay.
Das ist die wichtigste Ursache für diese Krankheit.
Gut, ja, wunderbar. Dann halten Sie mich bitte auf dem laufenden, was mit dem Patienten ist,
was für Ihre Untersuchungsergebnisse sind und insbesondere was bei der ÖGD rauskommt.
Gut, ja, vielen Dank. Okay.
Ja, wir sind jeweils ganz gut in der Zeit.
jeweils 20 Minuten ziemlich genau, das passt.
Ja, eigentlich sind Sie sprachlich sehr, sehr sicher.
Es gibt ganz paar Sachen...
Manchmal haben wir uns nicht so gut verstanden, dann musste ich mal nachfragen.
Manchmal lag es an einer etwas ungewöhnlichen Formulierung.
Aber beim Fragebereich waren Sie sehr sicher.
Da hat mir gut gefallen, dass Sie viele verschiedene Frageformulierungen angewendet haben.
Sie haben also gedacht, ist Ihnen aufgefallen, haben Sie bemerkt, haben Sie das und das.
Sind Ihre Beschwerden schlimmer? Sie haben eben sehr variabel und nicht immer das Gleiche gefragt.
Und was Sie auch schön gemacht haben, dass Sie den Patienten jeweils mit Namen angesprochen haben.
Ich finde das immer total wichtig.
Man muss das jetzt nicht bei jeder Frage machen, aber hin und wieder mal ist das ganz schön.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl gehabt, dass Sie nicht so richtig das realisiert haben, was der Patient bereits gesagt hat,
weil Sie das nochmal nachgefragt haben.
Da reagierte der dann ja auch immer so ein bisschen unwirschend.
Ja, so ein bisschen habe ich ihm doch schon gesagt.
Also da ein bisschen aufpassen, dass Sie das, was Sie bereits an Informationen haben,
auch wenn es nicht an der von Ihnen gewünschten Stelle kommt, aber dass Sie die Information schon abspeichern.
Gut. Ja, eine winzige Frage haben Sie nicht gestellt.
Das kam jetzt aus dem Forum raus, aus der Gruppe, dass Sie nicht nach Voroperationen gefragt haben.
Und Sie haben glaube ich auch im Status nicht abgefragt.
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Im Status haben Sie auch nicht gefragt.
Na gut, okay. Und jetzt kommen wir zum Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Wie immer ist das, was Sie frei formulieren müssen, schwieriger als das, was Sie an einem vorgefertigten Fragenkatalog machen.
Sie haben sich relativ wacker geschlagen bei diesem ersten komplizierten Satz, wieso der Patient sich vorstellt.
Das ist ja immer die erste große Hürde, dass man versucht, da unheimlich viel Informationen reinzustopfen.
Und dann geht der Satz am Ende schief. Also ich denke mal, das war ganz gut.
Gut, wo ich nicht so ganz sicher bin, Sie haben, ich weiß nicht, das müssen vielleicht auch Kollegen mir sagen,
Sie haben gesagt, er hat mediastinale Schmerzen.
Ja, Mediastinum habe ich irgendwie weiter unten. Ja, genau, Retro-Sternal, würde ich auch sagen.
Passt besser, passt besser. Gut.
Was mir dann wirklich krass aufgefallen ist, weil das hat der Patient ja ganz am Anfang gesagt.
Der hat gesagt, ich komme jetzt zu Ihnen, weil ich Angst habe. Und warum habe ich Angst?
Mein Bruder, der hat Schweizeröhrenkrebs. Ich will das nicht haben.
Das haben Sie tatsächlich im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch überhaupt nicht erwähnt. Sie haben die Eltern erwähnt, aber den Bruder nicht.
Und das ist ja eigentlich ein Grund für die Vorstellung. Und das ist natürlich auch ein Grund, um erhöht wachsam zu sein.
Wenn es da familiär das Ding schon gibt. Mal horchen.
Gut. Dann, ja, was mich gewundert hat, Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzen würden ausstrahlen.
Auf die Frage hat der Patient eigentlich gesagt, die strahlen nicht aus.
Ich weiß nicht, wie Sie darauf gekommen sind.
Ich verstehe die Strahlen irgendwo unten, hinten oder, ja, verstehe ich diese.
Hat er nicht gesagt, der Patient. Also eigentlich kann es nicht ausstrahlen. Sie sind dann nur so im Halsbereich.
Gut, okay. Missverständnis.
Und ja, es kam dann praktisch alles, wie Sie sagen, genauso wie Sie gefragt haben, haben Sie das eigentlich wiedergegeben? Schmerzgala.
Was Sie nicht so sehr gesagt haben, auf welche Speisen er reagiert. Scharfes Essen, Schokolade, also extrem süß, scharf, süß und Kaffee.
Haben Sie jetzt nicht dezidiert erwähnt, sondern haben eigentlich nicht nur auf dieses frühe, also späte Essen vor dem Schlafen gehen.
Und, ja, da so ein bisschen drauf versteift, aber gar nicht, dass bestimmte Sachen das eben auch auslösen.
Ja, ja.
Und? Ich verstehe, als Kaffee und Schokolade und später Essen ist die Ursache für die Gastrosophägealre flühen.
Ja, ja, wahrscheinlich. Ja, ja. Alles zusammen. Und, ja, zum Schluss kam noch eine Sache.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob ich Sie richtig verstanden habe, deswegen habe ich danach gefragt. Haben Sie gesagt, herzliche Enzyme?
Ja, herzliche Enzyme.
Herzliche Enzyme, ja. Herzliche Grüße, ja, das sagen wir. Aber herzliche Enzyme haben wir nicht. Aber das fand ich sehr süß, muss ich sagen.
Deswegen habe ich nochmal nachgewonnen. Aber, ja, Sie haben das so gesagt, ja, für den Fall, dass da tatsächlich doch noch irgendwas dahinter ist.
Gut, ja, aber ich denke mal, wenn man Troponin machen würde, würde man das schneller machen, ja.
Dann würde man sagen, oh, wir unterbrechen, ja. Aber so eine richtige kardiale Anamnese hat der Patient ja eigentlich nicht.
Und, ja, Sie haben ja auch noch sehr wacker die ganzen Sachen abgefragt, was weiß ich, wie Schwindel und Ohn macht und was auch immer.
Da hat er auch ja so ein bisschen ungehalten reagiert und hat gesagt, wieso ich bin noch hier, weil ich diese Schmerzen habe, ja.
Eigentlich, das, was mir am meisten gefehlt hat, ist eigentlich diese Geschichte mit der Familienanamnese.
Das finde ich einen wichtigen Punkt, das vielleicht so als Hinweis. Und sprachlich denke ich mal, sind Sie sehr, sehr sicher.
Wo haben Sie so gut Deutsch gelernt? Wo haben Sie das so gut gelernt? Haben Sie Kurse hier gemacht oder schon vorher in der Türkei?
Ist mein Deutsch gut? Ich finde ja. Also Sie machen nicht viele Fehler, wirklich nicht. Ja, und...
Ja, in Deutschland, ja.
Ja, super. Also ich denke mal, Sie müssen vor der Prüfung wirklich keine Angst haben. Ja, eigentlich können die Ihnen so nichts wollen. Ja.
Gut.